welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul
aka eddie brock brock let the devil in
in this video we're breaking down the
brand new trailer for venom let there be
carnage
that wasn't an invited thumbs down the
video by the way now the movie releases
september 15th in the uk
and on the 23rd in the us which means
we're in the august endgame now
there's a lot to unpack from this new
look and in it we'll be going over the
easter eggs hidden details
things you missed and how it links up
with the first trailer we'll also be
discussing what some of the plot leaks
say to add some context to the shots
so if you don't want anything ruined
then i recommend that you turn off now
also smash the thumbs up button so i
don't eddie block you
and make sure you subscribe if you think
the movie is going to be the greatest
love story of all time
oh yeah now when we last saw eddie he
was operating as somewhat of a vigilante
in the streets of san francisco
he and venom made a rule of no eating
people which we saw referenced in the
first trailer
the post-credits scene of the prior
movie and with brock being called to san
quentin by cletus cassidy
who promised him that there will let
there be carnage now he had written
welcome eddie in his own blood
and in the prior trailer we saw that
cassidy was writing a postcard to brock
in red ink
which may have been the same thing this
is the very same postcard that brock
gets in his apartment
and it brings everything full circle now
going off everything we've seen so far i
actually have a theory that cletus sent
his blood out
carnage was then born from venom and
became attached to it on the postcard
and then it came back into the prison
with brock cletus then potentially bit
into brock and
as it was already bonded with him it was
able to immediately latch on
if we jump back to the first movie you
might remember that the idea of hosts
having to be a perfect match with the
symbiote was paramount to them getting
attached to someone
and therefore carnage knowing in advance
that it can align with cletus through
his blood
would make it seek after him circuses
confirm that the sequel is set a year
and a half after the first movie
and we see how life has massively
changed for brock with him now living
in somewhat of a mess due to them pretty
much being an odd couple
you might have also seen that there was
a leaked featurette which dropped last
month
discussing the movie in more detail
though it was taken down by sony
circus said they were pretty much
constantly bickering like an old couple
and harrelson stated he couldn't believe
how funny the performance was
especially getting to see hardy without
the cgi just going off on himself
now we start with brock sitting on his
ducati which he had in the first film
he parked this in front of his work and
had a buddy moment with the security
guard
who you never know they might bring back
for this brock and venom are clearly on
different pages to one another
and they're disagreeing over a lot of
things eddie wants him to remain in
control
whereas venom wants to break free now
speaking of breaks he breaks eddie's
nose at one point
and you might remember that in the first
film he was able to fix wounds like this
pretty easily
so he doesn't mind doing it again
because of this constant back and forth
in the trailer
i think that venom might see carnage
roaming the streets and doing what he
wants
and he may even decide to join him at
some point carnage of course comes from
venom
and he represents the darker path that
venom could go down
brock returns to san quentin once more
and cletus says that he wants to give
him his story
we then see a dig being carried out in
which there are several forensic teams
looking for buddies we can also catch
cadaver dogs and it's clear that this
excavation is unearthing the remains of
several people
according to the leaks cletus called
eddie to the prison to reveal several of
his hidden victims
and this is why the authorities were
angry with brock for cracking the case
when they couldn't
we then see a headline for the daily
bugle which says inside the mind of
serial killer cletus cassidy
the first paragraph reads about the
exclusive report from eddie brock
in which they dig into his past and what
made him the way that he is
now brock seems to be working for the
daily bugle which is carrying the exact
same logo as what it was in the rainy
verse
in the last film he of course lost his
job and his fiancee
and he did end up looking for other work
this obviously isn't connected to the
raimi verse directly because
that already had that amazing venom in
it
but certain things do clearly come
across the mcu version is also an
infowars-esque parody
so that this will lead directly into the
universe and circus has made it pretty
clear that it's not connected
even though we know it's all connected
now how they handle the entire thing
with the multiverse we don't know as
no way home is supposed to usher in
several characters from across multiple
franchises
this has already been confirmed by
alfred molina and jamie foxx
i kind of feel like that movie will end
with the multiverse further being
cracked
open and the characters will then be
able to jump across
you might remember that when it was
announced that spider-man would remain
in the mcu
that kevin feige said he'll be the first
character that can jump across
franchises and personally i think he'll
be used to potentially bring eddie into
the main timeline
or they might just keep it separate you
just don't know
maybe maybe brock can do some
investigating to find out
why we still haven't had a spider-man no
way home trailer yet
where is it sick of this where is it
now just below the laptop we can see a
note from cletus and potentially this
could be one of the things he was
scribbling in his cell
it does look a lot like the child
drawings that were carved into the walls
and it says to thee the strife was given
between the suffering
this is from prometheus by lord byron
and prometheus was of course about
someone who took fire from the gods and
gave it to the mortals
we'll talk about the tie backs to god
later on in the video but there's
clearly a lot of religious imagery going
on
now in the comics cassidy was a complete
psychopath that relished the idea of
taking lives
and the power that murdering someone
could hold over them
when cassidy was growing up he was
actually abused by his father
who also beat his mother in front of him
cassidy gained a massive inferiority
complex
in which he felt weak in comparison to
his dad and thus the only way he felt
like he could be more powerful
or his equal was to cause pain to others
like most serial killers he started
torturing animals
and then he moved on to people sometimes
superhero movies will give you a villain
that you can relate to
but in the case of cletus there was
absolutely nothing redeemable about the
character
i think he's probably gonna be one of
the most sadistic and evil comic book
characters ever put to screen
i genuinely can't think of anyone off
the top of my head in the marvel
universe
that is as irredeemable as him and it's
going to be interesting to see how they
handle the pair
to make matters worse carnage is a
complete psychopath too
and together they're yeah they're just
the worst
people ever now cleous ended up killing
his grandmother by pushing her down a
flight of steps
and he also attempted to electrocute his
mother she managed to avoid this just
before it happened
and broken by her husband's abuse she
lashed out a cletus and attempted to
kill him
cletus's dad then murdered her but
whether he did it or
it was actually cletus we don't know for
definite cletus was then taken to the
saint esther's orphanage
where he was mocked further and he ended
up burning down the location
which we could potentially catch in the
trailers i think this shot is probably
set in present day though
and the pair that we see are likely
shriek and carnage who i think grew up
there together
they might be returning there to destroy
it as part of their rampage
which we'll get into more detail later
on in the video now cassidy is then
taken to his execution
and we know from the first trailer that
the blood inside him pushes the lethal
injection back
further tying to this idea of blood this
may be a nod to the blood of christ
further alluding to the idea that
carnage sees himself as a god
occurred to him with an altar and
candles around it and clearly he's
holding some kind of service
the way that he transforms is also much
different to brock's
and rather than the symbiote warping
itself around him it seems like it's
actually part of his body
potentially coming out of his blood
cells now in the first trailer we could
catch mulligan reading a paper with a
map behind him
that had the tenderloin district
highlighted with lines around it
shout out to eric vos from new rockstars
for pointing out that this is an
area in san francisco that has a high
homeless population
and this could mean the movie might pull
from absolute carnage
in that carnage creates carnage drones
out of homeless people
and there's a heavy focus on worshiping
the god null the title let there be
carnage could also be a reference to the
bible
namely the line let there be light the
movie also seems to be taking a heavy
focus on church
and crucifixion imagery so potentially
we'll get call backs to this comic
and how carnage is seen as a deity go to
the prison break which i'm guessing
happens in the midst of his escape
and we see how unstoppable he is as a
monster no matter how many bullets they
put into him there's no effect
and he warps his weapons around him
before sticking his tongue down another
dude's throat
which i'm sure happens in prison quite a
lot now we see more shots of the
ravencroft institute
and also shriek ravencroft is pretty
much the bell reef of marvel
and this location houses a number of
super villains
it was also seen in the amazing
spider-man 2 as being the amazing place
that elektra was experimented on
now in the comics both carnage and
shriek were prisoners at ravencroft
but together they managed to escape
shriek and carnage
are in a relationship and speaking of
relationships
actually googled heavy spoilers over the
weekend and top result in the related
search was heavy spoilers wife
i see you youtube i see you i know it
was you googling her 500 times a day
i know it was you now she's able to let
off highly powerful sonic blasts
i'm not talking about shriek there
you're having that
but we're also talking about shriek to
be fair now this is why we can see gods
around her cell
wearing giant earmuffs there's also some
soundproofing and metal doors to dampen
the noise
and potentially carnage is springing
here loose so that they can go on a
killing spree
this actually calls back to the comics
and after the pair escaped ravencroft
they went on one in new york
this would tie back to them burning down
the saint esther's home and we can also
see him attacking the facility
which we can tell due to the structures
around the building that line up with
how ravencroft looks
from here the helicopter swoops in and
we catch two people riding in a car
later we can see that this is shriek
driving so i'm guessing that the pair
have just escaped or that they're
driving away from saint estes
cletus finds out about ann through a
photo and we later learned that she's
engaged to the guy from the first movie
that's some of a [ __ ] actually he was
alright but yeah venom makes eddie punch
him in the face
potentially he might let carnage kill
her fiance and that would be pretty
convenient for eddie to just
slide back in i'm sure he's still got a
key
now he cut at the church in which venom
refuses to come out because
carnage is a red one this is clearly
calling back to maximum carnage
in which the finale took place in a
church i also think we catch cassidy and
mrs chen's store
kicking someone in the face he refers to
eddie as family
and tying back to the idea of blood they
may even be seen as blood brothers with
one another
everything goes to hell and the pair
face off and as always in these trailers
we end with a joke
which yeah just kill him just kill him
now we know that stephen graham is
playing a character called mulligan
which could be a nod to patrick mulligan
aka toxin
in the comics he was an offshoot of
carnage and just in the same way that
the first movie set cletus up as a
villain
we could see the seeds being sewn here
for venom three let there be toxin
now as for my thoughts on the trailer i
always say this yeah but i feel like
people don't believe me
i actually enjoyed the first venom movie
it's one of my guilty pleasures i'll
admit that but
i do have a lot of fun when i'm watching
it especially that lobster scene
now i knew this trailer was coming today
so i actually watched that film last
night
and it has got me quite excited for
what's to come i really want sony to
lean into that overly dark aesthetic
that the
mcu doesn't really do as this is
something that can really set them apart
just in the same way that the new
suicide squad movie was james gunn
turned up to 11
and not beholden to any overarching
universe or
reigns from disney sony has the
potential here to just go crazy with it
and show us some really messed up things
serial killer documentaries are some of
the most popular things online
and i think they have the opportunity
here to make people fascinated with
cassidy
even if they can't condone anything that
he does that's really what i want to see
in the movie
and i didn't mention this last time but
i'm actually surprised at how much the
movie
seems in line with the first one often
when you change directors the shots and
style look a lot different
but circus has done a really good job of
making things seem like a continuation
of the first
overall yeah really excited for it and
we have what if
shangshi and this all coming in august
in september
so it's going to be a great time to be a
marvel fan as always let me know your
thoughts on the new look below
and just to let you know we're running a
competition right now and giving away
three mcu box sets on the 30th of august
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe with notifications on
and drop a comment below with your
thoughts on the trailer we picked the
comments at random at the end of the
month and the winners of the last one
are on screen right now so that's you
then message me on twitter heavy
spoilers
if you want something else to watch then
we've just done a big breakdown of
suicide squad which will be linked on
screen right now
i know it's not out in the us but if
you're in the uk and have already had a
chance to see it
definitely go check it out as we've got
some cool easter eggs in there
and just our thoughts on the film in
general and where things could be going
if not then thank you for sitting until
the end of the video i'll see you next
time
take care peace